If some of that news that you're getting in these traditional venues is fake.
It is dangerous.
If any of it is click baity of any of it is deceptive,
not agree with you more.
It's fucking dangerous.
Especially because we have a president who attacks the presses and the,
and remember like,
let's not forget the context.
We're operating it.
Yes.
You know,
we have Trump calling us the enemy of the people.
So crazy.
The lack of understanding of history in some people's insane,
you know,
for sure there were easy to drive in saying though,
let's be honest,
there's a lot of dummies out there.
That's part of the problem.
It's just,
it's so easy to prod a certain group and the like,
I'm done.
I'm going to do something about this.
This is,
this is the danger.
This is what you have to worry about.
That people that they,
and again,
they're signaling to,
they're signaling to the far right.
They're signaling to those people.
I know a lot of people like that.
Not that would,
you know,
shoot people.
But I know a lot of people that are signalers that like far right's signalers,
like they'll see things and I've,
I've talked to people that I hope Trump wins cause we've got to put a stop to
all this nonsense.
What's the nonsense?
It's progressive nonsense.
The idea of socialist,
like Bernie Sanders is going to come along and take all your money.
We're struggling hard working Americans.
We've got to put America first,
put America first.
It's this lack of understanding about the complexity of the entire landscape,
the entire landscape in terms of economics,
the entire landscape in terms of international politics,
all of it,
all the above,
the,
the war machine,
the entire,
the,
the lack of understanding about the military industrial complex and the
influence that it has,
the lack of understanding about the bankers,
about how few people went to jail after the fucking crazy economic collapse that
we just recovered from.